pokemons go is out and it's absurdly
popular but it's missing a few features
that Pokemon fans would definitely
appreciate I'm Tony and this GameSpot
news update should help you catch them
all
the biggest thing Pokemon go is missing
is the ability to trade developer
Niantic CEO said that this feature will
be added in a future update the game is
already about meeting up and exploring
together so treating Pokemon will be a
natural extension of that poki stops and
gyms will also get new customization
options and a global leaderboard is in
the works finally there's a chance the
game may be coming to a our devices in
the future but Niantic hasn't confirmed
that one way or the other Pokemon go
launched on iOS and Android devices this
month but it's not out in every
territory just yet Niantic is still
addressing the server issues that are
slowing down the launch for some
countries stay tuned to game spot for
more release information and for all the
Pokemon news you need you're already in
the right place